[Music]
well that was a cliffhanger of an ending
well I'm very overwhelming oh my god
this is really happening when they all
showed up I wasn't even thinking like
about the dragon it was dragon I was
like oh I forgot oh no the second they
showed up I was like that's right
there's no way they would be showing up
if they didn't have this up their sleeve
was on my mind at the time oh yeah I was
so gripped and like what are you gonna
do like they've spent so long stressing
the importance the this purpose the wall
serves just a few short minutes with
enough white dragons fire took that wall
down holy core least enough of it to
come on through the next season is gonna
be batshit the thing with the dragons
sort of fast-tracks everything it's like
oh yeah our plan can move right ahead
everyone's scattered around nothing is
in place sir see it's [ __ ] lying
they're gonna go heading out finding the
White Walkers thinking they have an
alliance with Circe on this specific
battle oh my god I'm actually glad that
we have a break I'm actually really glad
yeah yeah this has been intense this is
just I feel like in Terry overwhelmed
and the last couple episodes have put a
lot of stuff in there like there's been
a lot to cover and a lot to get done
well this is a great episode all the
discussions were fantastic I was like
that was vintage Game of Thrones yes
like we moved back to having some great
scenes that were you know very much
character see as well as like political
debates yeah and it was so cool seeing
all them you know like a lot of
different reunions and how lot of them
have changed now that they're reunited
and the different alliances here and
there yeah it was very fascinating man
Cersei [ __ ] deserves to die first he
just won't get down with the program at
all Cersei is actually I really liked
what they did with her over the course
of this episode nothing is ever easy
with her and like that they hinted that
she has still a bit of a heart
even when her brother's tests are so
very much like and I don't know what
that means at this point cuz she does
not seem keen on helping this situation
out in any way well it seems like
Jamie's officially turned her back his
back on her
yeah realized I can't get through to you
like yeah we're gonna I don't matter as
much to you as just your vision matters
yeah and her greater power damn and I've
learned that you will not sacrifice you
know for me over that I thought for a
second she was actually going to get
killed I did say that I was so worried I
thought I wouldn't I would have actually
pissed me off if he if he got killed
both of them had a similar scene when
there was like do it if you're gonna
have him kill me just do it yeah but she
nodded her head she nodded her head yeah
I was like it's actually gonna happen
yeah yeah now one seemed big oh you know
bigger because like of course we would
be afraid of her killing yeah but like
Jamie is things are happening me knows
too and I do hope I know the next season
is gonna be a lot shorter than this but
I do hope that I don't know if they'll
get back together on-screen a lot but I
do hope that that storyline I'm excited
to see how it pays yeah
and Littlefinger dying I was thinking
that but I was like you know sometimes I
say [ __ ] and it doesn't happen yeah but
when it happened why why when the big
reveal was there when she calls his name
out in the court it does make the the
past couple episodes but more rewarding
because you know they did kind of trick
us into yeah you know there have been a
lot of people bickering over over the
Sansa and Arya plotline and and yeah
like thinking about it before like I
thought this could happen there were
times when I got pulled in I was like oh
man he really is driving them apart but
there were times where I thought like
they could go this way because she is a
lot more skilled than Littlefinger is
he's conniving as he is she's all
stealth you know yeah well also with
Sansa be manipulating you know I was
getting annoyed at the thought that like
she's getting manipulated yeah oh yeah
yeah yeah I'm glad we had that it's for
me that was like a fanservice scene
because it was like when they were in
the corn I was saying to myself don't
don't get manipulated again come on
songs uh but
and then that amount like oh it's gonna
be one of those Hollywood scenes where
she's gonna give the whole speech and
then go little finger you know Lord
Baelish
yeah yeah and it happened about I was
like [ __ ] yeah yeah [ __ ] little
finger deserves again [ __ ] humiliated
and killed yeah yeah totally [ __ ]
deserved a man none of your tricks
working here boyo she said at the top of
the season she's like I don't gonna
trust you yeah yeah I mean I appreciate
your help and all but you were not my
guy yeah yeah cuz she was given the
whole when Baelish was giving the whole
speech about trying to figure out
someone else's motives I'd like in that
scene I was thinking well I hope you're
thinking of baelish's motives right now
yeah totally what and you know like
adding spent so much time around
horrible manipulative men yeah I guess
in hindsight - it makes sense that she
would know deftly how to navigate them
and you know like the clarifications Jon
Snow yeah we finally go be an egg on
Targaryen hasn't his real name as Aegon
the man named after hey you gone it said
hey gone on the subtitles here that his
name is Aegon Targaryen snow that's
gonna be awkward for him guys Adam order
the condoms amazing yeah Rhaegar and the
aunt were in love man
that's crazy I don't know like a whole
war being built op like that war
happening all because of you should just
told why yeah if you were in love she
just told us and it makes everything so
much more interesting because it would
have been convenient if you know John
just rules with death Daenerys life you
know he's the rightful heir to the Iron
Throne so like you know is he gonna
create complications as Daenerys gonna
see John now as a threat to the Iron
Throne she's gonna really want it so
back as she feels she rightfully
deserves it but he's also family yeah
it's John gonna want to just go no you
deserve the throne you know you've done
a lot of the hard labor like you want it
more than yeah you brought this right
back yeah but that could be an ending
for it instead of John saying nothing
like I deserve the throne ax and you
know well they will they still want to
be together now that they find out that
oh you're really my aunt yeah your ends
are known for incest either way
it's like it creates a complication you
know oh yeah it's John he's gonna have
to be discussed it so because John will
have to reveal
once he finds out who he really is John
will have to reveal who he really is and
it's gonna be I'm sure I'll be a
identity crisis for the guy you're my
aunt and I'm the king like he's grown
what am I gonna tease still abusive
there's a whole talk he had with Theon
about you're a Greyjoy and historic and
I'm sure for him he's like well now how
much Targaryen and I'm a star he's not a
bastard at all I know not only am I not
a snow yeah or a sand I have a rival
Targaryen heir to the Iron Throne
yeah and it's our - yeah Oh raid I I
cannot wait to see this season unfold
this next one because there's so many
different emotional conflicts and with
the White Walkers Tara and the wall
their next step is probably Winterfell
oh yeah yeah next Pepin is on move in
there cold front yeah you know their
next steps Winterfell that's where like
Sam Sam brand killer yes Arya sanso
they're all all their little fingers
corpse but they show that Dany and John
are still sailing yeah I don't know how
many more episodes they can spend doing
that like we're gonna fudge the time
I'll make it realistic I'm gonna make
sure that you know how [ __ ] everybody
is right now oh man what the hell is the
season opener you're gonna be for the
next one I don't know how the white
dragon functions I don't know if the
night king can ride further out now that
he has a dragon or if they I get this
since they have to stick to where it's
cold you know they're yeah I can't swim
at some point or another I mean Circe's
gotta gotta take a look at that white
dragon and maybe reconsider it yeah her
stance a little bit
oh absolutely the other part that really
said I think it was beyond yeah on the
station he had with John and and when he
was standing up and felt like he earned
that moment he earned that yeah yeah
well cuz he's finally learning it seems
like he's just taking him a really long
time to learn how to do the right thing
yeah and that was so cool what he was
getting hit in the nuts have any so he
was able to a standing idly oh boy I'm
not a hundred percent of stigma yeah
that was a really rewarding moment yeah
people [ __ ] about fanswer
so I'm like [ __ ] you man she will suffer
all the time what give us some [ __ ]
fanservice man yeah want some damn
fanservice one at a certain point you
know you do hope that Theon will turn of
Gavin or you know and he's been through
a ton I mean but you see Ando sober like
not a hundred percent sold yet once he
rescues Yara
then I'll be sold yeah but this I feel
like this was a good step in that like
the fact he just took that beating he's
like I know I didn't cower away he kept
going for it to do what he believes in
so that was a really rewarding moment so
there's a lot to look forward to this
season eight man you know all these
everything we've talked about everything
so much after the final conclusion on
this i I really do respect and
appreciate how they divided this up yeah
I mean you know they're there there are
certain things that I wish had been
smoother leading up to this but
especially this episode and
recontextualizing or paying off some of
the things in the past episodes I
thought it was I definitely felt
rewarded by this one the hold
conversation - at the Dragons pit I
don't think we really talked much about
that that scene just that scene is a
tremendous you know just seeing all
those people seeing all that history
walk back into the same room and they
all get to finally stare each other down
and like each of those month like
there's so many to character moments
happening at the same time and like the
context of that and seeing that that
whole scene the way it was staged and
captured was tremendous well it didn't
have like all the shocking moment stuff
in there yeah it was it was probably the
my favorite moments out of that whole
episode yeah that was a I thought that
whole sequence was really compelling and
the things that came out of it - like
like when Tyrion goes to talk to Cersei
and stuff like that like I was really
pleased with how they handled that we're
like The Hound confronting the mountain
or Bronn and Podrick talking with Tyrion
finally Cersei and Daenerys and Jon all
meeting each other yeah there was plenty
of plenty there and then when the when
the white Walker came out - that was an
intense moment yeah yeah an intense
moment and it just makes you hate surfs
even more for a damn decision-making
well they played that moment beautifully
as hookahs for a couple seconds I was
like something go wrong yeah this is it
this is it just dead they're gonna watch
regular core
oh yeah that was yeah that was that's
tremendous alright guys well I hope you
enjoyed this season of Game of Thrones
yeah I certainly did that
I am I'm overwhelmed like exhausted from
it yeah yeah yeah I wonder how I'm gonna
feel like tomorrow in the next day what
I actually get a second to like let it
back in you know I might watch the
season before the next one comes out
because it feels like these two seasons
are gonna be like specific like harp
they're all everything's intertwined of
course but I feel like specifically
these two are like a part one season
part two season yeah I have that sense I
would probably want to you know and that
seven episodes not too bad to catch up
on I'll be really good to revisit with
all these lights pointing at us - yeah
yeah I'm just excited to revisit the
whole show finally it's yeah Oh what
once it all wraps up I will eventually
rewatch the entire thing yeah just as
long as it finales good yeah series
finale has to they all go off and become
lumber Jen
well guys subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification valve - on
Humphrey on Twitter and Instagram
and at the Greg albo we have real
rejects social media and become a patron
oject today by joining our patreon my
friends much love to all of you